president's lawyer Rudy Giuliani says
the White House has a list of demands
for the special counsel before the
president will agree to sit down for an
interview with him Giuliani says the
president wants to testify in Robert
Muller's Russia investigation but
Giuliani is cautioning him against it
Paula Reid spoke with the former New
York Mayor she's outside the special
counsel's office in Washington Paula
what are you learning about the state of
negotiations
well Giuliani tells me that the special
counsels office has already rejected a
proposal to allow the president to
answer questions in writing so the two
sides will be negotiating the terms of a
possible in-person interview and
Giuliani tells me he wants the questions
in advance and there are certain
questions certainly issues that are
off-limits and despite my pressing he
would not specify exactly what those
issues are and there's also this
question about confidentiality and what
if anything in this interview would
eventually be made public and Giuliani
tells me that he wants some sort of
agreement about that in advance and the
opportunity to rebut anything that the
special counsels office puts out Rudy
Giuliani as the former US Attorney would
have been on the other side of the table
in these negotiations earlier in his
life Paula what do we know about when
this interview might take place if it
does exactly if it does Giuliani tells
me he would like to push it back past
the North Korea summit which is expected
sometime in the near future he tells me
he does not want to take the president
away from that important work for what
will likely be several days that he
would need to prepare him for something
like this all right we'll stay tuned
Paula thanks